[Music]
[Music]
how you live and how you doing how you
feeling how you moving the lef koe man
in the house with warren sharp in here
and wild this is the first time this
season where we didn't get to talk
tonight before sorry I had a dinner date
yeah more important to me I know I would
have taken it too it was it was Dwayne
Wade yeah only it's weird when Dwayne
looks at you goes hey Adam and you're
like ah [ __ ] I just literally got in
here about 10-15 minutes ago from
airport the lines are moving as we
record this at 11:30 on Thursday a few
big moves one that you like as well I
don't know if you want to talk about it
yeah well we'll get maybe we'll get to I
don't think we will no no let's let's
get to it let's plan on getting to it
because it's worth talking about one
thing that I definitely want to talk
about right off the top is Cle Blakeman
we had a good run yeah I would say I was
thinking we might have like a gravestone
for Clete unders we already buried the
Eagles season this week so I didn't want
to bury I did see they've been - he was
tend to know and then decided to allow
and I'm gonna put it all on him
67 points but I'm pretty sure I saw that
there was not a single penalty called
against the Seahawks in that game I did
there were four penalties called the
entire game which is very unclean which
means he totally heard everything in
which I'll be honest I'm still going
right back to the well this week did you
see he which came no I didn't look it up
yet but I just feel like that was a
prime-time game where he's like small in
Carolina Atlanta I'm almost positive mmm
all right I'm gonna get better jump back
on I think that was just to scare people
away and I want to get that seat see
when the waters are muddied like I want
no part of it cuz I don't know what what
he's gonna do he might try to just
increase his averages like Bill
Belichick at the end of a game where
he's like totally crushed this a
opponent he'll start calling other plays
to screw up his tendencies right he'll
start you know using different personnel
so that's a good idea
so like cleat you know he crushed it
with the unders rye he's gonna just
splash a few overs now to make it know
I'm not gonna do it somebody also
tweeted they were like as soon as Warren
said I got a weird feeling or like he
should be investigated I didn't make
that and I was like okay maybe I should
listen to but cleat it was fun but also
screw you for not calling any penalties
I mean there were so many possible
penalties in the game anyway
how did you do last week we ever get the
chance to talk you how did you do last
week wasn't my best week okay now it
happens oh yeah of course it happens
yeah but this time of the year as we
enter week for - yeah okay you know what
I did last week and and this is
something that we should it's worth
discussing as like a lesson
yeah right sharp school on 40 like I'm
bear the burden of the brunt of this one
but I took three different totals and I
tried to play the half which I thought
was most likely to hit so I took two
first half's and I took one full game
and all three of the parts that I took
lost but if I had doubled up like if I
did first half a in full game would have
gone five hundred well split them and if
I did the opposite so on the first half
if I didn't do the first if I did the
full game and down the line I would have
gone three and out so that's like it
would I mean craft message here you
started doing the half totals okay so
this is this really is a sharp school
nugget nice we're gonna be sharing
because nobody else is talking about
this I love that you're a little bit
sick so your voice is so dramatic right
now nobody else was talking about so for
a little while now I've been playing
first half unders in a lot of these
games yeah as you get like catch-up type
[ __ ] that happens late and you try to
avoid that trying to avoid that and so
typically I don't play first half overs
well the books after doing this for so
many years the books have started to
adjust
so what we're seeing unfortunately in
the marketplace is we're seeing like a
total that's set at 50 and the first
half is 23 and a half okay so for a
while would it be 50 25 yeah 24 and a
half it would be it would be very close
to being even and now they're completely
shading the first half unders because
they're tired of guys like me and other
sharp guys bang and I'm on these first
half understand those games so I mean 23
and a half makes no sense like the total
is 49 and a half 50 right so what I've
started doing is giving them the big fu
and when they put out a total that's
completely shaded like they're doing and
with the first half numbers I'm betting
the first half overs when I like the
over I'm not just betting the full game
I'm betting the first half yeah so
you're double up you'll go over first
half and over yeah and the only reason
I'm doing that is because they're
[ __ ] well okay yeah of course you
encouraged if we do the 14 weeks yeah
but I didn't I didn't know like the
touch it was okay so because they're
there screwing around with the actual
number so badly if I like the first half
number I will go over so for example
there's a game we'll talk about it later
it was 47 was the full game but the
first half was 23 mmm so I'm betting the
first half - right and screw you guys
because you're giving me a good number
there and if the line was 23 and a half
I wouldn't have bet the first half right
because it was not a good enough number
but if you're giving me 23 and the total
is 47 I'm taking the 23 and the 47 mmm
so I love that you have a Robin Hood
mentality where you're like screw you
Nottingham Forest I'm gonna take your
money for the people
well it just it's frustrating the way
that they're adjusting the market the
limits limits makes sense they they used
to and I'm actually glad that they're
starting to come out with first-half
totals earlier because it was either
last year or the year before or the year
before that one of those three years
sounds like I don't know what I'm
talking about but is one of those three
years is when they started coming out
and they wouldn't post the first half
totals until Thursday Thursday at around
like 10:00 or 11:00 each day eat each
week they would roll out the first half
total so you would have full game lines
all week but you wouldn't have the first
half's until then mm-hmm and it was so
fresh and fresh trainers - yeah because
then you're just like Bing in the first
half's and a lot of times I'm waiting
til I can bet first half and game this
year they started putting the first
halves out way earlier way earlier but
they're doing this ridiculous shading
nonsense and so we're gonna try to find
any angle possible to try to beat him do
you do self scouting like do you look
and go you know what I've missed this
team a lot this year I'm gonna stop or
I've been all over this team do you know
which teams you've been all over which
seems you've been missing on so far yeah
yeah for the most part you're the other
thing that we do with self scouting is
like last year for example my overs
let's pretend it was like 55% 57% I
forget the exact percentage crack was
like dude you do you know that like if
you would just bet those in the first
half you you hit like 75% Wow
but like the full games just weren't
hitting the same as the first half and
so that's another reason if you're going
to give me better numbers and the first
half is playing more true to form we're
gonna take advantage of yeah yeah cuz
I've noticed like Buffalo has been on a
nice little surge recently with wins but
yeah the totals the totals aren't hidden
right now no and and you know okay again
you have been the only one that I've
really heard talking about dabble in the
booth and the speaking of the oxidants
and Bill's they go in there and they've
got a few big wins in their belt
therefore and won their last five but
either their defense is holding the
other team to preventing the / or it's
just it's just not getting done well so
the game against the Broncos was the
first one that I tried to do that was
week 12 and we blamed it on Brandon
Allen in the office that was when I was
sick and I couldn't be on the show right
and in Brandon Allen what was a dumpster
fire I think he averaged like 2.8 yards
per attempt or something it was nonsense
it was also windy that day and that
morning I didn't love that total I had
already bet it I thought the wind was
going to be X it turned out it was why I
kind of underestimated it's whether it's
the wind you can't really you know even
two days ahead I'm not going to be
exactly what you think it's going to be
last week though against on Thanksgiving
I mean that that thing should have been
a hammer to the over I have no clue what
Dallas was doing they were driving all
the way down I think they had four
drives inside the 30 and they walked
away with three total points yes I mean
because they missed field goals there
was that that total reformist field
goals like that there was for miss field
goes a missed extra point and they
turned it over on downs at least one
time they Jason Garrett's such it such a
let it out let it out this is a safe
space let it out about Jason Garrett a
guy is so reactionary it tells you that
he doesn't have a strategy you know for
fourth down him in the week before then
he went for it like every single time
that he got he got destroyed obviously
for not going for it New England put him
in the betting Hall of Fame and covering
+6 right and you were happy it was built
to statue to him but he then goes in
this game and just freaking just
haphazardly going for it on fourth down
to show you like hey I got balls I got
balls but the reality is like you know
you're just doing that because the media
is critical of you and that's not it
shows you don't know when to go for
fourth downs like this shows that you
don't understand the process I want I
want to clip out if I've got balls I've
got balls okay Wow you know what I
didn't do
fart I didn't calculate the update of
your EDS are last week how do you think
you did I'm gonna pull out I don't know
they have no idea I'm nervous
alright so week 13 I got it right here
oh okay you know who you're number one
for traditional EDS are and trending EDS
are was was it the Eagles Eagles yeah so
that was a loss Rams over Cardinals
for traditional Bangor Chiefs over
Raiders Bangor bucks over Jaguars super
Bangor that was great oh yeah that was a
three nothing like so that those three
did really well all blew out that was
tradition and how could the egos be up
twenty eight to fourteen and if we can
lose in regulation we've already buried
them you shouldn't speak ill of the Dead
trending ETS are you had Chargers over
Broncos didn't work out Jets over
Bengals we did not use because we saw
Andy Dahlen we said scrub it and Chiefs
over Raiders Tambov or Jacksonville
so from traditional was three and one
trending was two and two and then I
would also assume a traditional was
three and one against the spread and if
I do quick math that means that you are
two three and one two and two five and
three thirty and nine overall and twenty
four and fifteen and one against the
spread so yeah Eagles dolphins just a
menagerie of fuck-ups your number one
mismatch in traditional EDS are this
week is going to be a one o'clock game
Minnesota over Detroit again this is
factoring in the entire year we're gonna
do two traditional and then trending but
what are you seeing in Minnesota over
Detroit right now in this one o'clock
matchup we will align currently by the
way is Minnesota by thirteen which
explains the traditional EDS Armas yeah
I mean it's like typical you wouldn't
want to lay the point just because of
this the poor they probably have a
really good shot at winning this game
but from an 80s perspective it's it's a
lot of points for them to cover I'm not
in love with Minnesota's defense to be
honest with you you know apparently
after mother died I don't either
and Detroit you know their their offense
the reason the numbers are down is
because of their offense but I actually
I'm not I'm not hating blough I mean I
don't know they did downgrade over
Driscoll
so oh girls are running back
and Wow is Wow was chucking them in
college so he's chucking them here too I
was got good pocket presents I'll share
Thanksgiving I'm watching my family and
and Blau came out the first two plays of
the first drive and they were like ducks
and I was like guys this is why the
media is so funny they're looking at his
Purdue tape and as soon is so good
he ain't got nothing next play 75 yard
touchdown I was like I'm gonna shut up
yeah all right so we won't spend too
much time on Minnesota second game
though was the one we were alluding to
earlier in the show the the second
biggest EDS our mismatch for the whole
year is Tennessee over Oakland and great
but you said for the whole year which is
correct but you it sounded maybe to the
audience like this is like the biggest
mission of the entire season factoring
in EDS are for the entire season and not
just the last four or five weeks
Tennessee has the second-largest
EDS our mismatch of this week over
Oakland the line currently is minus two
that's where we saw some movement right
before the show started and this is one
that you're spotlighting you really like
Tennessee in this spot
well the EDS our model does I can tell
you that it's definitely gonna be a
square versus sharp game because the
sharp guys are going to be buying in on
the Oakland Raiders that is definitely
going to be the sharp side of this game
you can see coming off of a big win over
Indy where there was a number of special
teams plays that led to that Oakland
getting shellacked by Kansas City but
really when you look at it it's very
turnover based with pick sixes and a
pick at the very end of the game so
maybe that's a little inflated maybe
Tennessee's a look I could see why the
Sharps would get on Oakland there is a
big game for their season they're
playing back at home look up the statue
and I talked about it before Derek Carr
gets crushed every time he plays in
Arrowhead it's just a it's just a fact
the fact of life he sucks there so you
might as well just accept it he's coming
back home they've played two straight
road games they finally get to play a
game at home so if you like Tennessee my
advice right now the lines two and a
half I think you wait because honestly I
think that the sharp money is going to
come take Oakland Oakland and tee
etc up through the 3 and the 7 and and
you might get a better number on
Tennessee now the angle I like in this
game is the over I gave that out to
clients at a better number than what
you're going to see on the screen when
you listen to this podcast when it's
actually published yeah so like
literally we were about to start and
then Warren went hold on there's
movement and the line went from about
forty six and a half for the over/under
the total one from about forty six a
half to about forty seven and a half and
like the last five minutes yeah and and
and you still think there's value yes
you really like the over you reelect the
total in this one yeah you know just
breaking down a couple of the reasons
why it's surprising but Tennessee is the
number one red zone offense in the NFL
they are better than any other team out
there inside the red zone and that's
factoring in Marcus Mariota being a
terrible quarterback for the first six
weeks of the season wasn't ready for
that though
hawk it up gets get rid of that crap the
Raiders are one of the worst red zone
defenses in the NFL so you've got that
edge going for you it actually there
Tennessee's number one Oakland's number
thirty-two defensively so you've got a
big edge for Tennessee there you also
have the fact that over the last I think
four weeks
Tennessee is the number one most
explosive passing offense and the number
one most explosive rushing offense and
Oakland ranks number 28 in sorry number
31 an explosive passing defense and
number 28 and explosive rushing defense
so they're allowing big gainers
Tennessee's banged up in the secondary
they had the signs they had to sign a
new cornerback I don't know how the
status of the other guys that missed
gaint that game in Oriya I think they
have a little IR if he did it was today
because as of yesterday he wasn't but
he's he's definitely he was scissoring
crazy stuff I was reading some of his
quotes I don't know what's wrong with
that guy well he was getting banged up
in the last few weeks for sure he was
saying stuff like I'm just happy to be
alive
well like life is going to take care of
itself I'll get
out there whenever I can stuff like that
I'm like I never heard a player like
talk about so you're saying it may be
worse than questionable this week I mean
it's it's the Tyler Lockett thing was
like life and death right the
compartmental compartment syndrome
that's scary I think this guy just has a
twisted ankle or something we're on with
his ankle so don't think it's life or
death but he's definitely being pretty
melodramatic about what how he was
describing his mentality I'm certainly
not going to be one he's going to say he
should or shouldn't play through
anything like that I respect the hell
out of all these guys so that's not what
I'm getting at but the other the other
thing you just mentioned it with the
game against the Colts last week thing
about this Jacoby Brissette is the
quarterback you're without you're number
one wide receiver T wise out you're
without your number one tight end
Araki runs out you're without your
number one running back Marlin Mack is
out you were also out Parris Campbell
you are all and Jonathan Williams played
like nine snaps right so there Jacoby
Brissette goes in there and I think he
averaged over eight yards per pass
attempt he's mainly yeah he ever he puts
up 319 yards eight yards per pass
attempt they have scoring opportunities
on five of his first six drives but
freakin Vinatieri can't hit the broad
side of a barn and his shank and Potamus
and one of them then later on of course
they get he has a kick that's blocked
returned for a touchdown
then they fumble the ball on the Titans
13 yard line if they just if they forget
the fumble on the 13th let's say they
kick a field goal and make it and these
other three field goals that he missed
or got blocked if they just make that
the Colts without any weapons are
putting up 29 on the Titans defense okay
so without any weapons so I think Derek
Carr he's going to get back on track
here a little bit officers like Derek
Carr and 10l are both throwing for over
300 in this game and it's in California
so you're not as worried about the
weather like no I've been I've been
studying the weather it's very important
to be paying close
attention to weather wind speeds
precipitation amounts all that type of
stuff this time of year so we're gonna
be in good shape for this one
one other note Titans are one of the
more public teams getting bet thus far
66% of the bets are going on the Titans
and something going forward if we're
talking actual football or thinking
about the playoff race Titans Final Four
opponents have a record of 32 and 16
which is toughest in the NFL but this
will be an interesting game everyone's
very riding very high on Ryan Tannehill
everyone is kind of thrown Derek Carr to
the curb and you know Jon Gruden is
gonna be saying let's be a nightmare and
let's ruin their dreams this week so but
I think the point that you said sides
I'm not sure
total though there's clearly a side that
you like and it makes a lot of sense
yeah third biggest EDS are mismatch this
week when you factor in weeks one
through 14 for the statistics is the
Chargers Chargers taking on Jacksonville
they started off as I believe a one
point favorite it has ballooned up to a
three point favorite for the Chargers
over the Jaguars Jaguars really in free
fall
ever since cut now Gardner Minshew is
back after Nick Foles is benched and
it's insane to me but this this we're
also going to see them popping up in the
trending EDS are what other information
do you have in this matchup
you know to be honest with you it's very
hard to have a to have a side here
because the question is is Jacksonville
quit or not I mean you look at their
effort generate some hate betting on the
Chargers I just want the state that yeah
I mean I I don't want to touch this
thing at all either way because this is
the type of game though where both these
teams had aspirations of making
something out of their sanity the I I
think it's like gloves off like I think
this is like a bare-knuckle fight like
you don't know what's gonna happen
you got Phillip Rivers just chucking and
ducking potentially gardner minshew with
the mustaches back out there
like he's pretty up and down he could be
on he could be off so I think there's a
lot here to process but the way Jackson
has been playing the last couple weeks
and how their defense has been
performing and they just thought they
just put miles jack on IRS they did yeah
I wouldn't touch this game at all this
is a game where if you bet one of the
sides and they win by 30 you're like I'm
a genius but it could go either way
I would probably lean Chargers but I
wouldn't touch this game yeah I mean EDS
are will get to training in a second but
definitely likes the Chargers here the
last biggest mismatch for traditional
EDS are Atlanta is currently -2 versus
Carolina Cam Newton obviously on the
Shelf Ron Rivera gone it was minus one
and a half it's gone up to two and the
public loves the Falcons here 67% of
bets thus far are on the Falcons before
we talk about this game the fact that
the new owner came out Dave pepper and
in part of his little interview with a
team reporter said that they're really
gonna start embracing analytics and
they're really gonna start embracing New
Age football and Ron Rivera was a guy
that was the heat vehemently old-school
I don't really want to talk about that I
gamble when I want to gamble and Dave
temper comes with from a background of
the Pittsburgh Steelers and a very proud
organization when you hear that how much
hope does that give you for this
franchise moving into the future because
I saw the analytics community online
really going hey guys this will be good
for the Panthers in the long run oh yeah
I mean look it's it's it's simple it's
what is it I don't want to say evolution
I don't know if that's the right word
but this is just the path that we're on
trying to like stand there and resist
the wave the tide is coming like and and
trying to you know prevent analytics
from seeping into your team and helping
you make decisions that's all analytics
are its
understanding numbers better help you
make more informed and educated
decisions how to optimize the decisions
that you make and it's not something to
be scared of so I like the fact that
he's trying to incorporate a little bit
old school a little bit new school I
think it could be a pretty good balance
the key is with any of the analytics
ventures you have to have the coach buy
into it right so I feel like he's gonna
find a coach who would buy into it it
would really make no sense what Coach is
gonna go into an interview these days
and be like I don't like numbers like
who's gonna do that then like John Fox
well that is funny you say that because
that's one of the things that I'm kind
of well I don't want to say anything
about it right now but we're gonna get
some of the coaches speaking the
language that they ought to speak during
some of these interviews so they are
they gonna call you for prep nice I love
what I can see it the other coaching
things Perry fuel is gonna be taking
over for the Carolina Panthers and I
don't know how they're doing this but
Scott Turner now is like calling the
plays it seems like and they've moved
north to like an Isis fighter yeah which
is like if you're gonna be replaced by
anybody
your son is probably the guy you'd want
to be replacing that's the only reason
North has wanted to come back and do
this I'm sure
the deposition of his son well I mean
look you're right in that sense but in
the other sense like put myself in his
shoes or like my dad right with what my
dad tried to do with me you know my dad
was in the construction industry and
when I was a kid in high school during
the summer I would go work in their
office I he was one of three founders of
this company and I will go help out do
various different things and their whole
goal of that company well obviously was
to make money for the families right
that's the provide but the secondary
objective was to build up a nice
business and then eventually like the
kids might be interested in taking over
the
now I decided I didn't want to do that
right and I pursued other ideas but you
know I think there's there's a lot of
negativity around like the the thought
of nepotism but if there is a deserving
person who has earned their stripes he's
put in work and David Tepper I listened
to his quotes about Scott and it's
encouraging yeah he said Scott's got
some really good ideas I want to see
what he can do this is like a trial for
him I want to say I watched the full
Dave Tepper interview and I came away
going this is not reactionary this is
well-thought-out
I thought he answered everything right I
thought he gave respect to Ron Rivera
like in a really strong and passionate
way I can tell usually right away if an
owner is one of these pretend owners
that just likes to like go to the
parties and hang out or if they really
want to build something I knew that Dave
temper was serious after the All or
Nothing on Amazon when he said as soon
as the season is done I'm building a
bubble because I'm tired of you guys not
being able to practice it'll be up and
they're like well it could be delays he
goes there will not be any delays it
will be ready by the season Dave pepper
is a really really good odor I could
just tell already with what he's doing
in Carolina and I was worried because if
you remember when he got hired there was
a story about having him having brass
balls on his desk
remember that started remember that now
I'll find it later well no I agree and
I'm sure that like I'm curious how
different Scott's play calling will be
from North's and maybe we get a taste of
it this weekend it's a challenge because
I looked at their schedule and you know
Atlanta's that weird defense right where
they switched everything around we're
kicking ass for a couple of weeks and
then last week you know the floodgates
open and they allowed a bunch of points
to this New Orleans Saints there was a
fumble return for a touchdown and all
that stuff but true yeah and and
Carolina's schedule over the next couple
weeks is pretty difficult in terms of
the defenses that they're going to be
going up against so he's got Scott's got
his work cut out
him but look if he's the one thing I'll
say about the job the Turner's did in
Carolina is it exceeded my expectations
with their ability to work with cam and
get him into that system integrated
passing the ball efficiently accepting
check down accepting check downs
throwing the ball to the running back
when I mean the the he didn't do that
for like his entire career the whole
like narrative from like so many
different people are you know well if
it's a running quarterback he's not
gonna throw to the running back he's
just gonna run the ball you know and
they got him to throw the ball to the
running back and it was a very efficient
offense and looked a lot different from
the offenses in prior years so they've
had injuries they've had to deal with
jams been getting injured that he's the
key focal point I mean that style of
offense is going to be much different
from another quarterback that you stick
in there and they really didn't have
like a seasoned backup it's not like
they had Derek Anderson know around who
they could just stick in there oh you
know the playbook you've every they're
getting young guys who don't have any
experience in the league really to come
in and play undrafted guys so I've been
impressed
so in this matchup to just kind of do it
briefly this is a matchup where I think
Carolina got embarrassed a few weeks ago
this is when Atlanta turned their tide
after the by you have a new coach in
there how do you approach a game like
this or is this a little bit like what
we were just talked about with chat with
chargers Jacksonville where you're like
there's a lot of things going on and
it's too much for me to handle right now
typically when there is a coaching
change it provides value because a lot
of times it's a coach that wasn't
performing players were fed up with the
guy maybe only was there for a couple of
years time for somebody new like you
know picture-picture
Shawshank Redemption we're standing out
there in the rain yeah okay that's what
a lot of players are like after they're
a coach they don't really love rights
let go but in this case like everybody's
coming out how much they love Ron Rivera
so the organization obviously heading in
a new direction
I think it would be important to try to
impress the decision-makers but are
those decision-makers even going to be
there next year like you don't really
even know so there's more question marks
on this coaching change than there are
sometimes God show yeah oh he's beloved
I mean people coming out and saying
they're depressed that he's leaving like
camp I don't know if you use the word
depressed okay I was gonna say but he
did say he was like it would be in some
foreign language he would be in that
foreign language you know with the
little C big R with a slash through the
two dots over letters and your slashes
through everything alright let's go to
trending EDS are and this is four weeks
correct yes okay four weeks the number
one EDS are mismatched in trending what
do you know
the Chargers over the Jaguars the game
that we've already said or probably
gonna stay away from the number one
trending EDS are mismatched last week
was the Eagles over the Dolphins maybe
this could be a new trend for us betting
against that just kidding we're gonna
stay away number two trending EDS are
mismatched you have a note next to it
because again we don't know what we're
getting with the cult's it is the cults
over the Buccaneers and that's an
underdog Buccaneers favored by three I
believe is that still the line yes so we
have an e dias or mismatch now I'm not
sure about Marlin Mac we're still
waiting to see is Tyreke is a tym
already out I think he said he doesn't
even know if he's coming back this year
so I would assume that they did that
he's out but I don't know e bronze out
and there's it out for Sheldon iron
Paras Campbell is back and I saw Evan
Silva was tweeting that every time Paris
Campbell comes back they feed that guy
so if you're playing daily fantasy or
he's probably on waivers for a lot of
you guys I saw week four and week nine
he came back and he got like nine
targets in each of those caves remember
he was a high pick for them he's a super
fast guy and they really don't have that
many other guys and if there's a team to
feed against it is likely the secondary
of the Tampa Bay Bucs I know that all
those
injuries are scaring you and I know that
you've kind of been on the bucks for a
lot of games this year
but when trending gives you a an
underdog what do you see in this
mismatch a lot of questions a lot of
questions I think Tampa Bay is still
playing hard the Colts there I don't
think Frank Reich is gonna let these
guys not give a full effort here
they're just undermanned you know they
just don't have the same horses it's
crazy if you think about what the Colts
were to start the year I mean even even
Andrew Luck but you know Funchess and T
why and-and-and in Paris and Ebron and
Marla Mack and all the like all these
horses and and now they're just down to
like who is a guy caught like the Pascal
yes Pascal you know the number one wide
receiver form it's crazy yeah I don't
really have a tough guy a preconceived
direction that I'd be looking in this
one if anything I'd probably lean to
riding with the EDS are but it's it's
tough it's like a motivational type spot
you got to figure it out figure out from
a handicapping perspective the
motivation and with the votes in D you
don't know who the kicker is going to be
and that's been I just I think though I
don't think it's gonna be finitary no it
it's gonna be doubtful and I'm hoping
it's an excuse to just get him out of
there
an interesting stat about kicks this
year that Ingeborg fond there have been
210 missed kicks thus far through 13
weeks the most by far second-most was
back in 1992 a hundred and eighty seven
so that's 23 more already there's 2000
to 2001 1991 what do you think about all
these Smith's kicks other than it's
really frustrating because it's [ __ ]
up a lot of overs for us this year yeah
that's very frustrating on I've given
some head coaches my strategies on on
kickers oh I would love to hear this if
you would like to share with us
yeah look kickers obviously play an
important role they decide get a
touchdown plus each game I mean you
assume in a couple field goals extra
points etc that's seven to nine points
each game it seems like a lot of these
guys they lose confidence and then
they're just done and I think that
position more than any other even a
quarterback even a quarterback when you
get to the NFL level there's just like
so much pressure because you're staying
out there by yourself by yourself you're
making or missing it where's a
quarterback he's throw into a receiver
ran the right route he didn't you can
blame this guy you could blame that guy
oh he dropped at all these different
excuses a kicker as long as the laces
aren't pointed at you you're expected to
make that kick and when these guys don't
it's a problem and so I would be heavily
invested in sports psychology for all of
my kickers and different technique well
the week type of stuff throughout the
week in the offseason I know there's
restrictions on the amount of practices
right from the CBA so I would be having
my kickers have setups at their house or
they can just practice themselves I'd be
doing other things that are integrating
them into the team a little bit more
because yeah they really easily they
really feel separate from the team and
and they're doing their own things and
their own drills and the coach doesn't
want to waste time with them because I
got limited time that could practice my
other guys so you guys just dick around
over here yeah with the punters and and
so I've been doing other things to try
to get them there just I have a lot I
would in their area
I would replay clips of their best kicks
on loop like them making kicks because
you're right it is interesting like the
psyche of and it's how many guys that
are really good really good kickers like
like you could go Vanderjagt you can go
huh they that finitary you can go up in
on New England what was cows Keselowski
all these guys
so money and then they miss a couple and
then it's just like they can never get
back on track and you have to like cycle
them out of there
except for your doppelganger Justin
Tucker Tucker is he's I think he does a
lot himself too of psychology it's funny
because when they like to joke that he's
the opera singer mm-hmm and what is more
scary than standing in front of people
and singing oh isn't that like the
number one fear of all humans and that's
a fear but but I think it's either like
public speaking or public singing is
probably yeah yeah probably you're right
he says he's more scared he's come out
and said that like he's it's more
nerve-wracking for him to sing in front
of an audience right than it is to kick
the extra point I saw there was a lot of
after he kicked a 49 yarder to win in
the rain when Robbie Gould couldn't even
reach the end zone what was that it was
Robbie Gould his current status my god
there I saw a lot of the analytics
community really showing how far above
replacement Justin Tucker has been that
his baseline of expectation is the
ceiling of the number two most reliable
kicker in the NFL and it's it really is
such an incredible weapon and to think
of the evolution the Raiders over the
last five years
we're with Flacco it was we need to win
17 to 12 but it's not 17 with a
touchdown it's five field goals and the
safety Justin Tucker went from I'm gonna
carry this team to now he's this secret
weapon on an offense that's one of the
most efficient offenses we've seen in
the 80 years of the NFL and it's it's
fun that it didn't all go to waste
because I think for a long time it was
like wow Tucker's the only reason this
team is seven to nine or eight and eight
and now he is the cherry on top to this
offense it's been cool to watch it all
evolve yeah it's funny it's funny
because Tucker is the best by far but
there's still rain and mist kicks that
he has that I remember because it cost
me games he had the stats the Saints he
had one this year both of those cost me
bets
so I remember that type of crap and
that's that's unfortunately like that's
what employers remember too about right
their employees like you could be a
great employee you could be doing like
your job ninety five percent of time you
have one mistake like at your review
even the next year you're always gonna
remember that random thing that you did
that just like pissed them off this
sounds like this happened to you it
happens to everyone thank you I don't
make mistakes all right so the third
trending ETS our mismatch is an
interesting one we're gonna dive deeper
into it in a little bit
Rams over the Seahawks has started off
Seahawks were favored by two and a half
on the road and then I don't know if
it's because the sharp just said what
the hell are you doing it's now been bet
to a pick um should we wait for this yes
to it later we'll get into that later
but just so you know trending adsr has
the rams they're a little interesting
tuck that away in your little cumberbund
number for trending EDS are mismatched
the Jets over the Dolphins it started
off as the Jets were favored by seven
and a half and now it is down to five
and a half I see right out the win it's
at five
I assume this is because of the Miami
Dolphins and everyone's getting very
excited and the Jets fell all over
themselves and lost to the O and 11
Bengals do you have any insight on this
one that you'd like to spotlight not at
this time I mean that game against the
Bengals last week there was a lot of
offensive mistakes for the Jets I wasn't
really good to watch that there was
there was penalties that brought back
big gains they were just it was just
really really bad and I think this is
what the Jets put up 34 and three
straight exactly 34 points in three
straight games before that one and then
throw up six and then throw up six so I
think they'll be able to get back on
track a little bit here the it's hard to
want to go against obviously the early
money was was riding with the beard
Fitzpatrick it's hard to go against him
right now and he's just nothing to lose
like a complete mountain man just
psychotically playing the game but
yeah I mean at some point the Jets have
the better overall team yes more
complete roster 53 and they're spending
all week getting this around that and
Rev and they have already lost down
there in Miami yeah
and then also Miami their win of the
year over the Dolphins with a trick play
that has been in the a block of every
Sports Center I've watched this week and
yeah like I would I would want to go
Jets here I don't feel comfortable
laying five and a half yeah but you know
I probably not doing anything with this
side okay good to know I you know I'm
gonna text Sam and say hey I don't know
when I get in trouble for that if I
texted a player and said hey I just bet
on you guys to win by five would I get
in trouble for that
because we saw Josh Shaw from the
Cardinals he be betting on games now
that's different
he had the sign a he had to sign a
policy NFL gambling policy which
prohibits him from doing that
gotcha you you don't work for the NFL
you haven't had to sign that so I would
never do that because I think that would
like I don't want to get trouble and
it's like not worth my time
no it's yeah I've talked about this
before I think it was with my home's you
know you you're a celeb so you got like
all these guys in your rolodex I mean
you could like but you don't want to you
don't want to talk to him about that
because then you're like these guys will
never talk to me again they they don't
want to be involved with somebody who's
trying to screw around with that well
yeah plus it's like I don't know no I
mean I want to because I think it'll be
funny but I don't know darn ins got
enough problems man we got to just keep
this guy clear mono so until the
season's over that's what I was
wondering would you make out with
somebody that public like very publicly
had mono weeks before I I have no idea
what the life cycle is of mono but I
hate any type of sicknesses so yeah I'd
be and be worried about it alright let's
I don't know what the [ __ ] we're talking
about let's get into the big
Gamze the week the first one I think is
going to be an absolutely phenomenal
game for one o'clock so much on the line
the Niners after the Seahawks win and
they fall to the Ravens in what was
supposed to be the game of the year they
go from having a bye and the two seed
down to being a wild card and the five
seed taking on the Saints and Drew Brees
who very quietly are making a run at the
number one seed and as I said before I
believe whoever against the number one
seed in the NFC is winning it all or is
going to the Super Bowl because I think
that the home-field advantage is in the
NFC are that big right now for this game
most of the public money is going on the
Niners at 68% just some other
information it started off as Saints
favored by three it's been bet down to
two and a half total went from forty
five down to 44 I just want to make sure
is that's still the same 44 hours so
it's starting to bounce up Saints are 5
and 1 at home this season
Niners 5 and 1 on the road Saints there
are 5-1 at home but there are 3 and 3
against the spread Niners 4 and 2
against the Sprint this is what I
thoughts interesting Niners are allowing
15.3 points per game but on the road
they're doing better they're only
allowing 14 point 3 points per game and
this is a good little nugget from ingmar
drew Brees against the number one
overall defense heading into the matchup
which the Niners are is six and one
lifetime with a 124 passer rating in
those games so every time the match out
him against the number one defense he's
six and 124 passer rating that is some
common knowledge that can be found I
turn it over to you for the in-depth
sharp analysis
well first you talked about home-field
advantage and we've talked about that on
our show right okay then it's not
actually that important I think it was
my own feelings has a big home-field
edge yes okay so New Orleans
but let me go down this list when you
have to win this season this season and
we talked about home home field has
changed it's it's different even this
season so like yeah you could look at
the last like five years but even like
the last couple of years it's starting
to change this year when you have two
teams that have winning records after
week four okay so they've gone through
the first four games and they're above
500 not at but above 500 as long as that
road dog is not off of a by which we
know that causes some problems in there
catching seven or less points eleven and
three against the spread and this is one
San Francisco versus Baltimore at this
very last weekend San Francisco covers
Buffalo Dallas on Thanksgiving in Dallas
Buffalo won the game outright Dallas in
New England Dallas was catching six and
a half up in New England
Dallas covers that game Colts over
Houston a couple weeks ago when Seattle
beat San Francisco in overtime that was
one they were catching six not there
when Minnesota went into Dallas and beat
Dallas when Baltimore and Lamar go into
Seattle and beat Seattle all of those
those are just a few of the examples in
the last few weeks that you know when
you start factoring in and these are
some places that have decent home-field
advantage right New England they were
outstanding
yes Baltimore has a really good
home-field advantage
Seattle has a good home-field advantage
and and yet you still get these teams
covering those games so when I'm looking
at this one I'm trying to factor out
your gonna if I think San Francisco is
the better team which I do and you're
gonna give me three points I'm gonna
take that three points and there's a lot
to talk about here but just look at
who's been tested most recently right I
mean it's not even close Green Bay and
Baltimore the last two weeks for San
Francisco the San Francisco they also
played the Packers they played the
Seahawks yeah yeah you said Green Bay so
they also played the Seahawks like two
weeks
three are the last four games that got
the Ravens Packers and Seahawks every
single one of those teams first place in
their division nine and three record or
better who of the Saints played they
played the 309 Falcons twice and the
five and seven Panthers in the five and
seven bucks all in Division they won
those gained only one of those games by
more than one score they for those games
they won one by more than one score I
think they're gonna have a challenge
against this defense I don't think
they've played a defense like this I
really think that this is going to be a
game where Kyle Shanahan he used to
coach against Sean Payton he used to
coach against Dennis Allen yeah in when
Dennis was the DC he's still the DC for
the Saints the last two times that Kyle
coached against him you know what they
did
Oh tell me 42 now 37 points per game as
my guess they put up 45 and 38 Wow now
that was like 42 yeah
wow that was good play goes very good
guess that was when the Falcons were
like this blitzkrieg offense though I
mean they had 38 points entering the
fourth quarter in each of those games
the San Francisco team is not like that
at all right totally different but one
thing that's interesting when you look
at you know San Francisco and you know
kind of like the the struggles that
they've had with different players
coming in and out of the lineup then you
get a healthy roster this week I think
staleys coming back he's fine he's
coming back where he's coming back
you're not playing in the rain do you
know do you no I do not I'm just gonna
tell you in advance I don't they ran the
ball on frickin 90 is either 90 or 95
percent of their first downs in the
entire game last week okay that sounds
crazy 19 rushing attempts only two
passes on first down how the hell does
Baltimore not like figure that out right
but they were still having success doing
that and that's because of the rain here
it's a dome Kyle's gonna be able to open
the whole offense up call whatever types
of plays he wants to I think I think
he's
there's just a lot of edges I was
watching that game on Thanksgiving in
the evening and latha didn't have any of
their receivers and another tight end
and and in freaking Eli Apple look like
he had no clue all these pass
interference penalties committing them
all over the freaking place and now
you're telling me that you're gonna have
like play-action and you're gonna actual
real NFL receivers running down the
field and he's gonna be able to deal
with that and Kiko Alonso and AJ clone
are questionable and they're facing
Jorge Kittel and and in breda and these
other guys out of the backfield Tevin
Coleman catching balls so that's where
those middle linebackers are covering it
sounds like you're leaving Saints just
kidding so I think it's gonna be a great
game I don't think it's going to be as
lop side is I'm indicating Drew Brees
and Sean Payton definitely get up for
this but you you know that San Francisco
did not go home this week oh I love I
love it too some people are like oh they
messed up their travel schedule they
went down the Tampa Bay I'm like you
know what before big games he last week
they didn't need that game last week
against the Ravens they obviously were
trying to win right this game in
division when you can get a victory and
give a Saints a loss yes our in
conference massive for home field
everything like that this is the game
and now you're telling me that they
stayed out on the East Coast didn't have
to fly all the way back and forth rest
it up buddy DUP team chemistry I love it
when guys hang around and don't go get
distracted by their families right like
I love my family but when I need to work
is better not to have distractions yeah
you know just honest to god truth and
these guys need to be focused leave
their families back in you know San
Francisco we're out here in Tampa
working all week gaining that
camaraderie I I really like that element
of it that is clearly the one you're
probably hottest on will go quickly
through the other ones Ravens bills
Ravens favored by five and a half in
Buffalo it started at five it got up to
five and a half bills are just three and
three against the spread at home overall
the bills though eight and three and one
against the spread for the season Ravens
having an incredible year
but six and six against the spread
Ravens are averaging nearly 40 points
per game on the road bills are averaging
19.8 points per game at home and the
bills total has got under in four of the
last seven games a little surprising
seeing a number like six for the Ravens
on the road here what do you think yeah
I mean from a pure numbers perspective
you're not getting any value betting
Baltimore right now
no value at all you're gonna have to lay
a premium in order to take Baltimore and
so that's why they set the line as they
did by the way that eight three and one
for the bills is the best spread record
of any team in the NFL this year okay
both of these teams are gonna have
advantages when they try to run the
football
it's it's one of the biggest weaknesses
of Buffalo is the run defense they
really haven't been tested all that much
they've played the third easy schedule
of opposing rushing offenses Baltimore
is the number one they do it in a very
unique way I've heard a lot of the
discussion that it's going to be easy
for Baltimore though defensively to
prepare for a lat Josh Allen because
they're used to dealing with Lamar
Jackson and Josh Allen scrambles a
little bit too that's one of the reasons
from what I'm hearing that they were so
well prepared to deal with the Shaun
Watson right because Deshawn wants to
run around a little bit but these guys
knew how to seal them in and keep them
in confined in the pocket so that's
something that you you know it works for
both teams right because both have sort
of mobile quarterbacks and both defenses
have been preparing a little bit I'm
interested to see what Shawn McDermott
does with the extra time to prepare I'm
interested to see what Brian day ball
does with the extra time to prepare
we've talked about it we were the first
to really mention this publicly about
how they've basically switched in the
first three quarters at least nothing
but a love and personnel hurry up get to
the line of scrimmage quickly they're
running at a tempo that's as fast as
what the Rams were doing they balls up
in the press box not the press box but
the coaching box calling in audibles to
Allen before that 15 second the clock
hit the play clock gets to 15 he's
helping them get them injury
play is it's it's gonna be a great game
I'm really looking forward to watching
it as of this point in time you need to
be aware that there is a little bit of
wind mmm in the forecast it's from what
I'm seeing about 16 to 17 miles per hour
but the gusts are like 34 to 35 miles
per hour
so with that guaranteed they're gonna do
the exact same thing they did two weeks
ago when it was Buffalo hosting Denver
they're gonna show the shot of the
stadium with the flag whipping in the
wind and everybody's gonna be like holy
crap and so we're probably gonna get a
little my guess is we're probably gonna
get a little bit more late under money
on this one
closer to kickoff I've done nothing on
this game as of yet one just a little
statistic here the Ravens play blitz the
most in the NFL 48% of draw backs and
Josh Allen has a 109 passer rating
against the Blitz since week five with
seven touchdowns no interceptions we
good game it's gonna be a great game one
last thing it's not a nugget but an
interesting factoid that I plan to work
on in the offseason is I'm really
intrigued with sim pressure so I'm going
to be studying I like fake pressure drop
out simulated pressure coming from
different areas drop those guys back
into coverage I really think that and
we're getting off topic but this will
tell me that some pressure is the
equivalent of play-action passing I knew
it
pre-snap motion but yes because it's
before the snap happens and it really is
the only thing that a defense can do to
try to regain that upper hand you know
you're on a seesaw right and the
offenses are getting all the benefits
their way right the scale is so far in
their motion guys and that throws off
the defense they can do a play-action
you think it's a run but it's actually a
pass I never and the rules are already
ingrained you do a draw yeah and and so
yours it's a loaded deck right like it's
already in their favor and then they can
add all these other things to it the
only thing that defense really could do
it's so reactionary is Tsim pressure
before the snap get that often spherical
[ __ ] we got to cover this guy you know
motion is and then and then the defense
doesn't actually come
if it looks like a blitz but it's
actually not a blitz and actually all
the receivers are covered but the
quarterback now thinks he has to roll
this way or the line thinks they have to
block this way it's one of the coolest
things that I think I'm really looking
forward to studying more often this
offseason awesome
Chiefs Patriots speaking about a team
that used a lot of sim pressure against
a great young quarterback last season
that's what Bella checked it against
mahomes in this game Patriots favored by
three is that still the line yeah
Patriots are five and OH at home but
just three and two against the spread
their last five or in the five games
this year Chiefs are 5 and 1 on the road
and four and two against the spread
she's averaged just under 30 points per
game on the road Patriots I can't
believe I'm saying this or averaging
19.8 points per game at home and they're
allowing nineteen point four points per
game at home Patriots have not covered
three of the last four Chiefs have
covered three of the last four if the
Chiefs win it will be the first time
that three quarterbacks under the age of
25 have beaten the Patriots since the
year 2000 before freaking Tom Brady and
again the Patriots play the most man
coverage in the NFL but we saw last week
when they think they need to switch to
zone against the Texans and the Chiefs
have just as many weapons they will play
zone as well where do you where do you
want to start here I want to start with
something that we were first on again
and that was that the Chiefs sorry the
Patriots defense everybody was talking
about these guys historic historic
that's exactly the words they were using
the best ever number one overall of all
time all this other type of stuff and
and what did we say on the show like
there was even a clip that BR tweeted
out pump the brakes on these guys
because they've played a easy easy
schedule and they're about to play some
teams that have good offenses and guess
what they played Baltimore and got lit
up like a firework on the 4th of July
they played the Houston Texans
you seem out of sorts Houston was like
abusing those guys moving up and down
the field on him and they played Philly
in Dallas but both those games were to
inclement weather so we really didn't
get to see if you could have called up
to the heavens and and and in Bill
Belichick and Ernie Adams are up there
creating their weather machine it's like
oh crap we're about to play Dallas let's
get the let's get the typhoon in here
let's dial up you know the the swirling
winds the sideways rain like it was
ridiculous and that was perfect because
they only want that game 13 to 9 right
if you don't have that weather I'm very
confident that Dallas might actually
beat them in Foxborough with the way
that their that the Patriots defense is
handling these opposing offenses so yeah
I'm concerned about the Patriots defense
I don't think they're as good as their
forecast the good part here is you got a
lot of experience with Annie Reed with
Patrick mahomes from how much how and
the way that they played them early in
the season versus in the playoffs night
and day different in terms of how you
know that game ended up going over the
total but it wasn't as easy for Patrick
mahomes in the postseason it was a lot
of screens and running back dumped on
the way Kelsey and well they invented
the strategy to face mahomes which is
you double-team Tyreke he'll anywhere he
goes with your number two with your
number two and you put your number one
on Kelsey but really what it was is they
played a lot of zero coverage zero
coverage man-to-man
that's what Patricia did to mahomes this
season also and that's what my homes had
to come out and go we need to figure out
a way to beat this so now he gets this
test again yeah
so I think it's gonna be fascinating I
know that there are some sharp guys I
think they're going to be on the
Patriots because it looks like a cheap
price the public's on the the Chiefs hey
how often do the Patriots lose at home
how often the Patriots lose after a
prior loss all those different trends
and angles it's going to be fascinating
because I think one of the one of the
things that the that is most underrated
about this game is just how good the
chief secondary is playing right now so
it's going to come down to whether
not the Patriots can actually run the
football and you know say what you want
Sonne michele has not looked the same
running from 11 personnel as he was when
he was running behind a fullback and
they've lost two fullbacks to IR they're
not running any 21 personnel it's it's
all 11 personnel and yeah that's why I
don't understand you know who am I to
question them but I would be going up
tempo the entire freakin time they have
11 personnel they're using majority 11
personnel why go slow it's not helping
you at all and I remember later in the
game Brady was like screaming at his
team a team was early in the game that
was after the second drive no it was
like after the second drive he came back
and gave that dissertation and my that's
my curiosity everyone says it's easier
to go and hurry up when you have three
wide receivers in the field but if it's
a rookie a guy that doesn't really play
like maybe they just don't know the
plays that well enough for them to go up
tempo I would see that is a good excuse
and I would think that that would be the
case for 31 other to the Oakville
O'Brian's team you know for example but
who is better prepares his players than
Bill Belichick and it would just be
shocking also is worse at drafting wide
receivers the Bill Belichick I'm being
[ __ ] serious like he's never really
hit Julian Edelman was undrafted to see
that team Joe Jackson to kill Harry and
doing [ __ ] and and that's why they're
going out and getting Randy Moss
types of guys in free agency all their
best receivers Chris Hogan was from the
bills yeah he's good at like west walk
it's his weakness dolphins yes Wes
Welker was like I could not believe that
he frickin Bella check out Wes Welker
man that was anyways what I what I would
think though that anything that you can
do to get a slight edge over those if
you don't think your wide receivers are
all that great then why don't you use
more no huddle you call up call on the
play with a hand signal whatever and
that because that's what these guys do
in college all the time I still have
there's no put the secondary on their
heels a little bit why
take longer it's not so I just wish they
would speed things up a little bit but
this game's gonna be great for me it's
gonna be either a Sammy Watkins or a me
Cole Hardman game because when you play
the Patriots just pretend you're number
one guy is gone who beat the Patriots
last week Kenny Stills it wasn't DeAndre
Hopkins had a few catches that were very
big but it was stills then at the big
one this is like a me Cole Harmon or a
Sammy Watkins you beat Belichick if you
have a good three and a four number one
and two and healthy and he'll and LeSean
this this you can run on the patience of
Westbrook said this on Monday that he
believes that they're saving LaShawn for
the playoffs he played for Andy Reid he
played with LeSean McCoy
I believe he knows something but that
they're cut because if you lose a game
LeSean McCoy it's like they play him a
little bit in the first quarter and then
it's like Damien Williams Darryl
Williams and then now the rookie that I
drafted in fantasy and he didn't play
and I dropped him and now he's really
good
Tara Williams telling the IR what's his
name he's got a good name [ __ ] all right
look it up let's move on to the other
game though
Seahawks Rams as we wrap up this was the
game that was the third biggest mismatch
in trending EDS are and it actually had
the Rams again Seahawks opened at two
and a half that is now a pick'em the
total one from 47 to forty seven and a
half Rams at home 3 + 3 + 3 + 3 against
the spread Seahawks on the road six and
oh five and one against the spread Rams
are actually scoring less at home they
drop more than three points per game and
they're allowing almost four points per
game more it's weird
no advantage for the Rams I'll tell you
why in a second Rams have hit the under
and eight of their 12 games this season
including four of their last five the
only reason it's not five for five is
because the Ravens hit the over by
themselves in that game Seahawks are
allowing much less on the road and drops
from 24 to 19 and the Seahawks are four
now against the spread in their last
four games
let me hear why Jared Goff plays better
at home he's got splits like in his
career it's pretty evident at this point
in time look at the defenses that he's
played at home so far this year
Darwin Thomson by the way is the guy I
forgot okay
number seven Saints number nine bucks
number two 49ers number eight bears
number four Ravens
Wow he's played nothing but top ten
defenses at home which explains why I
argued context which explains why they
aren't putting up as many points which
is why his home road splits don't look
as evident this year come in the
overrated Seahawks defense that he lit
up in Seattle a few weeks ago yes so I I
likened I don't know if you like this
this reference okay but I liken the Rams
to this like fighting analogy okay they
they aren't anymore the pound for pound
offensive champ of the NFL No right
there they're not that they've been
reduced to a neighborhood bully okay who
is capable of beating up on the inferior
kids Arizona Cardinals Arizona Cardinals
any crappy defenses right that you throw
their way they can put up points on them
I mean Cincinnati they're putting up 24
37 on the Atlanta Falcons 30 on the
Carolina Panthers right that they could
steal these guys lunch money right they
can beat them up they can make
themselves feel good but the thing about
them is they're a southpaw and they can
also go up against this good fighter who
doesn't know how to fight south pause
and that's what the matchup is against
the Seattle Seahawks interesting because
Sean McVeigh knows how to play the
Seattle defense really does they score a
boatload of points every time that they
play Seattle if you look at the points
the last four games where the hell is it
here 42 36 33 and 29 right they should
have had 32 if their kicker doesn't miss
a field goal and they would have won
that game when they met earlier so I
look at it as they're gonna enter this
game with a lot of confidence with a lot
of swagger they got back on track last
week they got their receivers back on
board Jared Goff was on pace to beat
norm van Brock
all time passing yards in a game record
they pulled him in the fourth quarter
hmm I did not know that like he was on
pace to therfore like six hundred yards
last week really Robert Woods almost had
200 yards in the first year that
Cardinals defense was just a disaster -
but at any rate so I think it's going to
be interesting for for that offense and
how they're gonna match up on the other
side of the ball like I don't think
people realize what Tyler Lockett has
been dealing with so because I saw like
the fantasy community is like he the
last three games I think he has forty
five yards maybe he's got four catches
in the last three games so he goes up
against the number one pass defense on
the road he gets injured this is San
Francisco he was in the hospital for
like two nights two or three nights with
this court prep carp carp compartment
compartment told something syndrome in
his legs big bruise that could be like
life-threatening at times he was limited
in every single practice leading up to
the last two games now he comes back
from that game and he was limited and he
played outdoors in the wind in
Philadelphia right limited you know his
first game back
Ross was off the whole game didn't do
anything in that game it was windy na
good game and then they play the Vikings
but guess what he didn't even practice
Friday he's dealing with the flu right
so he's limited from the leg and he's
dealing with the flu he practiced in
full not even listed on the injury
report on Wednesday so I think you get
Lockett you get DK Metcalf DK played
them obviously week five but he's a baby
at that point like rookies yeah now
you're in week 14 yeah I mean it's your
- you you feel like an old man at this
point like it's old hat where it wears
before your you know you just got on
your training pants and you try not to
make a mess in there when you're in Week
five but now he's he's almost ready for
his depends right he's such an old man
and then they of course got Josh Gordon
who wasn't there previously so I really
think that
my biggest concern for this game so to
be honest with the total right now is 47
yet there's been some sharp money that's
bet the under here now my biggest
concern is that in that prior game Brian
Schottenheimer and Pete Carroll ran the
ball in like 64 percent of their plays
and those run plays gained like 3.9
yards per carry and freaking rust was
averaging like 10 yards per pass attempt
and they're still running like 65
percent of the time I don't know what to
do about that like it's frustrating like
I want to I want to be able to insert
myself in some capacity to just increase
that and maybe that will happen in the
future but for this game it'll be
interesting that the the Rams have a
good defense but they haven't played a
good passing offense like what Seattle
has for a little while so you got a you
in any way in that one I think the I
think it's pretty surprising that the
Rams aren't catching more points here so
or aren't laying more points I think
it's cheap to take the Rams that pick
them right now I really do I'm curious
to see if it crosses the number it is
it's it started to this morning there's
a couple of the sharper books are at one
Wow favoring the Rams I see that and I
think that what's CR is Chris what's
that bet Chris it's just as offshore
sports book in Costa Rica Oh gotcha
so there are sharp book yes yeah they're
they're sharp book yep them and pinnacle
I won't mention the other ones can't
give away too many Nuggets here but yes
they it's starting to move in that
direction I think it's going to continue
that way all right let's call crack I'm
just gonna ask crack for what he wants
some what he thinks but also while we
call him can't believe the Eagles get to
play Eli Manning this is either gonna be
the greatest Monday night of my life or
the worst month you know like a couple
other guys are coming back for the game
to like Evan Engram is coming back I
think I filled and Tate's coming back
Eli Manning is 116 and 116 hey crack
we're talking about Eli Manning and
the Eagles lose to him I might just bury
myself in a hole and never talk again
like an ostrich my god yeah I agree
after last week God again these well I'm
not actually talking about Philly though
but yeah you know the Giants are
sometimes is is definitely out right
he's done
yeah he's well hello he's maybe not for
the full season but definitely out this
week but but if Eli regains cuz he's
he's 500 for his career 116 and 116 if
he gets a win against the Eagles and
then never plays again and so he
finished his career the winning record
because of us that would [ __ ] me oh I
want I wouldn't because if he goes if he
retires with a losing record Oh
I mean his his Hall of Fame like debate
gets so much more difficult I I don't
know about yet you think so
I think the fact that you can say he
doesn't even have he is a losing record
you're right they very they know much
more weight even though it's one [ __ ]
game yeah they would say that hopefully
and and who knows maybe in like five
years when he's eligible will forget how
that losing record came about but yeah I
would be surprised if that's the that's
the straw that breaks his back millions
in this career though it's amazing all
the money these guys make having a
losing record you're like they're saying
oh my god I know the only people that I
know that make that much money are the
subscribers of sharp football analysis
calm and the crack win app available
right in app stores now crack well we're
going to keep this tight is there a game
aside or a total that you've already put
in you've already circled or you already
like that you'd like to share with the
33% you know it's funny I just bet New
England here I'm at the stop point I've
seen it moving offshore minus three
minus a quarter at some of the sharper
shops and still at the stop point here
at three because South Point doesn't use
the juice they just go three or three
and a half so I've got two thousand
underwing one minus the three here
thinking that you know that last week
was a very disappointing game of course
this New England case he can be the game
of the week
I like the Patriots to rebound a little
bit here but usually I went back to
watch onside that's not [ __ ]
but on an NFL side where it would be a
medium-sized better or smaller and even
a smaller bet on a college basketball
game so I'll have them in the contest
and and I just spent some money on that
game I think that everyone's talking bad
about New England they're phonies
they're fakes and just at that Mericle
combination of Belichick and Brady you
gotta remember what we're talking about
here let me please oh yeah you go you
gone well Buffalo on both the war was
there everyone I don't know and I
haven't talked to Warren about this at
all I don't know anyone trying to find
someone that has a sharp that likes
Baltimore
everyone likes Buffalo this week it's
the game of the week everyone's talking
about and 75 percent of the public 75
percent of public right now is on
Baltimore okay you know playing the best
team in football Baltimore just seems
like no sharps are on Buffalo and I
think it's maybe Baltimore's due for a
letdown this could be the letdown week I
love it please tell me you had Ohio
State against North Carolina on
Wednesday yeah the sharp guys absolutely
we're on that side that's very good
that's uh yeah good good stuff let me
get onto one more game okay get off here
because this is it's important for me to
talk about this team again war on the
head I'm not talking about this Miami
Dolphins I mean my first sort of jet to
losing to Cincinnati but Miami Dolphins
have been doing so much better it seems
like than the beginning of the season
and it's been covering games they're
beating they beat two different teams
now as a double digit underdog this year
as a 14-point underdog they beat the
Colts now last week they go in and they
were I think there were ten and a half
100 gloves first the Eagles last week
and you know I need the Eagles to win
the division so that really bothers
saying I can't take take this it just
say I got a lot of money on this bet so
kind of really I don't know I'm rooting
against Dallas tonight I just don't know
if the Eagles has what it takes to one
of the vision but anyway after last
week's game but I'm gonna stick
Miami again here listen we all thought
the Jets were going to be a different
team after they beat Dallas they won
they rolled off a couple winds up in
Jacksonville they want some games I just
after losing to the Bengals last week
look could be the talk in the locker
room of losing to the the bangles and I
just if I see this line opened up at 6
and there are six is out here in Vegas
stations coast I'm looking at their
sixes teenager Scott I think that Miami
is going to be a contest pic of mine and
I may even bet them so crack is loving
the AFC East New England Buffalo and
Miami of course the Jets playing Miami
crack you're the man dude I hope you had
a great Thanksgiving
thanks guys great holiday holidays both
you guys happy holiday season
and I'm headed to New York myself
tomorrow whoa hit me up if you got free
time all right buddy
talk to you later crack check out the
crack winds app I love when he says
things like I haven't talked to Warren
yet cuz I look at Warren a morons like
don't say anything that's gonna give us
a giveaway any of our value it's good
did you give away anything no no okay
it's it's because he and I do talk about
a bunch of things I mean we talk about
games a couple days before I'm I'm gonna
take them we're gonna take them
I'm just getting prepared trying to
figure out the right time I mean market
timing is very important the funniest
thing for me about NFL betting and we're
gonna end right here and we can start
the music in like 15 seconds is that the
smartest betters or betting with the
casinos and so when the entire public's
go in Baltimore everyone in Vegas not
just the casinos but the the groups and
they can go out with they're going
Buffalo and it's funny that it just goes
to the statement the public is usually
wrong and you would and you want to be
on the side of the casinos you don't
like the casinos you want to beat the
casinos but you also kind of want to be
on their side I just think it's funny
more often than not that's what's gonna
bring home the bacon that's why they
have those statues and the pools and
bottle service and all that Lauren feel
better enjoy the games let me hear this
any final message for the 33% we got
some great games this weekend so hope
hope your wait years go well you know
and because these games are gonna be fun
you don't want to ruin your Sunday right
by losing money watching great games so
let's let's let's win these guys comb
through the the podcast find some
nuggets lef Co koe man for Warren sharp
angler with the statistics market
everybody back there the booth with the
audio appreciates you guys
homies enjoy the games a holler into
next week
[Music]